جود الاسكان منصه الكترونيه انعكس اثارها
على 36 الف مستفيد حصلوا على مسكن ملائم
بعد ان ضل السكن حلما يراودهم طوال حياتهم
ام علي عاشت طوال حياتها في منزل مستاجر
وامس تمتلك شقه ازاحت عنها عناء اثقل
كاهيلها
وما اجار تعبني مره حتى عيالي ما كان لهم
مصروف ولا لهم مدخل ولا شيء كان يلا
نوديهم المدرسه حتى احيانا انه ما اوديهم
يقعد اسبوع اسبوعين ما يروحون المدرسه
كلموني وقالوا لي انت حصلت على شقه من
الاسكان قلتي نعم قالت تحبين تمتلكينه قلت
له ايه خلاص سوى كل شيء
واعطوني الصك تعيش ام احمد في هذا المسكن
منذ سنتين غيرت مشاريع وجود الاسكان
حياتها وحياه ابنائها بعد تملك منزلهم
كان ساكنه في الدخل
تطلع عليهم سنه ب 16 الف وانا كان ما عندي
الا الضمان داخلي واولادي كلهم طلاب
بيدرسون بنات والحمد لله لما قالوا قدموا
تحصلون بيوت يعني في الاسكان
بلاش معي يشيلون من الضمانه
الحمد لله سينضم للسيدتين وابنائهم ثلاثه
الاف وخمسمئه اسره من الاسر الاكثر
احتياجا في السعوديه بعد اطلاق مبادره
اكتتاب جودي الاسكان الخيري التي حققت
ارقاما قياسيه من كبار المساهمين في ظل
استمرار الاكتتاب فيما تبقى من ايام شهر
رمضان
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض